we don't know about you but here on the
macrocosmos team we find it hard not to
smile as we launched tardigrades with
their cute pitch-black eyes and little
feet ambling across the smooth glass
surface of the microscope slide moss
piglets water bears whatever you call
them they're fascinating to watch and
even more fascinating to try and
understand they are a puzzle and we
humans are the puzzler and so we figured
sure we've already focused on
tardigrades in a previous episode but we
cannot possibly leave it there after all
like the microscopic world around them
tardigrades always have more to show us
our water bears are collected from ponds
and growing moss environments that give
them the water and food they need to
thrive and so behind the scenes we like
to give them a bit of attention making
sure that they are well fed and
comfortable in their slides after all a
drop of water is barely anything to us
but to a tardigrade a things so tiny and
so good at surviving that drop can be
everything tardigrades of course live
their lives absent of any kind of
intention to teach us anything they
don't even know we're here
but watching is a form of interaction
and one that reveals the interface
between the micro the macro and even the
cosmic so let's start with a part of the
tardigrade body whose weirdness we
haven't had the chance to fully
appreciate here yet their mouths in the
opening of the tardigrade mouth is a
distinct ring giving way to a tube that
connects to the pharyngeal bulb which
helps the tardigrade suction out the
juicy content
of its meals but to get to the juice the
tardigrade first needs to pierce its
target relying on a pair of stylus that
poke out of the mouth ring when it comes
time to feed when the tardigrade molt's
they shed their stylus and replaced them
with a new pair tardigrades are
omnivorous they're open to eating
bacteria plants and animals for some
species their meal might even be another
tardigrade but for the species here our
samples contain plenty of algae and
plant matter for them to dine on
collected from the same watery and
earthy worlds as the tardigrades these
bits of organic matter keep them
well-fed like a built-in buffet but
there are other times where bearing
witness to the micro cosmos takes a
little more adaptation on our part
recently we found a water bear with its
half shed cuticle filled with eggs still
attached to its body in what amounts to
parenting in the macro cosmos as you
might imagine we were more than a little
curious to watch these eggs develop but
if you keep a slide on a microscope for
too long the water will evaporate taking
with it the moisture the tardigrade
needs to exist outside of its desiccated
dormant state so he kept these slides in
humidity chambers and took extra care to
make sure the coverslip
wouldn't crush the developing
tardigrades and then we watched
the tardigrade though was still this
video is from our sixth day of
observation the only sign of life being
the absence of decomposition three days
later we can see the eggs are developing
and there are even little tardigrade
heads appearing the mother still seems
the same attached to her eggs and
seemingly still alive despite her
complete stillness when it comes time to
hatch the embryos will use their stylus
and pharyngeal pump to make their way
out sucking in water to increase the
pressure on the egg from the inside
until the shell breaks but we're still
waiting for that day to come with this
tardigrade brood embryonic development
and tardigrade can last from five days
to more than 100 varying by species and
dependent on environmental factors like
temperature the thing with biology no
matter what scale of creature you're
looking at is that you are always on
their schedule not the other way around
[Music]
food and birth probably seemed a bit
domestic compared to some of the more
recent tardigrade II and exploits he may
have heard about earlier in 2019 Israel
sent a spacecraft called Bereshit to the
moon taking with it
among many things a digital archive of
almost the entirety of English Wikipedia
and also thousands of tardigrades dried
out in their ball-like ton form and
ready for liftoff seconds before
Bereshit was supposed to land however it
lost contact with Mission Control and
crashed instead leaving one very obvious
question what will happen to those
thousands of tardigrades potentially
spilled across the surface of the Moon
our seeming penchant for sending
tardigrades into space has taught us
that they are able to tolerate vacuums
without liquid water of course the
tardigrades will remain in their dormant
state maybe if someone is able to return
to that crash site decades from now they
might manage to find tardigrades that
survived that crash and there's a chance
that with a little water they could come
back to life we're still working to
understand all of the tricks of
tardigrades survival how does it play
out in their DNA and proteins and why
some tardigrade species seem to be
better than others this is part of the
fun of tardigrades and our collective
fascination with them we're all learning
together here on planet Earth like a
giant science classroom asking important
questions like is that round thing the
mouth and what does happen when you put
a tardigrade on the moon
maybe this is our 21st century remix of
Apollo a conversation between micro
cosmos and good old-fashioned cosmos
science is ultimately a mix of
deliberate and accidental questions
taking on many forms to suit our
available tools sometimes science is a
detailed study and sometimes it's a
crash landing it can be a collector of
microbes and a master of microscopes
carefully tending to samples to meet the
needs of their invisible residents and
sometimes it's you watching along making
your own observations and maybe even
thinking of new questions that no one
has ever thought to ask before thank you
for coming on this journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us and thank you to all of these patrons
all of these wonderful people who make
it possible for us to take care of all
of our microscopic friends and bring you
these videos once a week here on journey
to the micro cosmos if you want to see
more from our master of microscopes
James check out Jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us we've got a lot of videos up now
check them out at youtube.com slash
micro cosmos
you